I think I've seen a number of different
kinds of recruiters to be successful in
the US in particular it's very candidate
driven it's very process different it's
very offering value consistently I've
found in the US is people that are very
diligent very organized very consistent
people that can deliver product
consistently you need 12 good months to
have a good year so it's about someone
that can turn up and kind of repeatedly
do it
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his and on this week's episode I
was joined by Rory Maddox he's one of
the co-founders of a business called
Talisman advisory Partners they're based
in LA and this is where Rory has been
building his recruitment career since
2015 although he started in recruitment
in 2012 over the last two years you've
been building a business with your
business partner called talism and
advisory Partners but you've been in the
recruitment industry for over a decade
now by end of year one we're at 15
people 1.2 million net fee income year
two got to 43 people 3.5 million net fee
income so in this conversation we break
down how they've approached growth in
the last two years what's really cool
about this story is Rory partnered with
someone who had never worked in
recruitment before we went into a lot of
detail on the operation
and the infrastructure that Rory and his
business partner has been building and
has invested in from very early on to
facilitate scale and they've approached
the go to market strategy in a really
interesting way which I'm really excited
for all of you to learn from in this
conversation you started it with Andy
who's got a different background what do
you think he maybe made you see or made
you do differently at the start that
maybe you wouldn't have done if it was
another recruitment person you think
yeah I I think a lot really particularly
around the kind of
enjoy this week's episode Rory welcome
to the podcast thanks for having me mate
as I was just saying uh
lucky really back from the states
obviously we got introduced to each
other was anticipating doing it remotely
but back here sorting some Visa passport
things and then we're gonna get back to
do you call it home now La is at home I
think so mate yeah I've been there nine
years I don't have any plans to move
back so I guess it's home yeah
and we got the business there now right
so that's that's our HQ so how do you
know Phil just curious like how do you
not feel about the UK when you come back
to
I love it you know I still miss it
obviously my family and friends are over
here
um so I try and come back to you three
times a year I'm from a place called
Medway in Kent and then I love it there
when I go back so I usually try and come
back for at least a couple of weeks you
know with the the time difference in the
jet lag and along so uh so yeah it's
great love that so let me just give
everyone some immediate context then in
terms of like the journey that you're on
I think today what I'm really excited to
dig into is your recruitment
entrepreneurial Journey so uh over the
last two years you've been building a
business with your business partner
called talism and advisory Partners but
you've been in the recruitment industry
for over a decade now before you started
um uh tap you were you know at two
different businesses one for just over
six years I think you know have a track
record of being you know top performer
on top of all these things but what
we're really interested in talking about
today so in terms of the last two years
so you started this business with Rory
whose background isn't recruitment which
I think is quite important which we'll
go into yeah I'm Rory he's Andrew yeah
yeah so you're this is fine Andrews yeah
um so yeah you've got the 10 plus years
of Recruitment and these like M A
consultancy or not it was it emerging
Acquisitions was like his background
yeah his background started off as a
chart and accountant moved into
Investment Banking Investment Banking
was was an m a advisory guy yeah cool so
always wanted to grow this business from
the very start you started in July 2021
um by end of year one we're at 15 people
1.2 million net fee income year two
which obviously we've just uh got to 43
people around 40 recruiters around six
people in the I put infrastructure we're
gonna get more into that and around 3.5
million net fee income most of it has
been perm but last month launched
contract is that right and then there's
a few other product lines as well that I
know that we mentioned and then your
Market
um you might have to help me out here so
how lies ESG sustainability or is that
wrong no that that's that's right that's
one of our teams that's one of the teams
yeah but you've got the whole life cycle
yeah so so we we do clean energy and
sustainability clean energy is obviously
renewable energy power production you
know across a few different asset
classes solar wind Hydro geothermal and
then sustainability is the other side of
the coin it's using less energy using
less waste being Greener basically so
it's all part of the same world but yeah
few different teams and then just as
we're talking about that would you mind
just talking about the smart thing
you've done about that's your they're
your Market that's your industry but
then you set your team up specifically
to serve every part of the Journey of a
like a sustainability business if
they're going through X they'd need this
this would you mind just breaking that
down because I think then that'll be the
perfect context yeah definitely so we
we've got nine teams so ESG
sustainability is one the other rate
renewable energy and if you think about
building like a solar power plant right
you're going to go through different
phases as you go through that life cycle
so at the start you're going to need to
do the origination development like a
property developer but for power plants
so we've got a team that recruits those
folks then after that there's a bunch of
contracts you need lawyers we have a
team that recruits those lawyers then
you need investing so we have an
Investments team then you need
accountants to balance the books we have
an accounting team four different
engineering teams a construction team
and asset management team the idea being
we can go to a solar client and say hey
we do everything you do Soup To Nuts but
we do it with very specialized teams
that whole through your value chain
which is great for them they get one
company that they can partner with one
message to the market all that kind of
stuff but it's great for us because
we've got eight different teams that can
penetrate the same client and then we
proliferate around them so yeah client
spend absolutely love that so let's
start with the the million dollar
question then sure you thought more and
more about this if you've been hiring
for your business so common
characteristics and traits that you
believe make up highly successful
Recruiters in today's market yeah I mean
I I think I've seen a number of
different kinds of recruiters to be
successful in the US in particular it's
very candidate driven it's very process
different it's very offering value
consistently so I I I've found in the US
is people that are very diligent very
organized very consistent people that
can deliver product consistently less
sort of sales in relation relational
than maybe the the UK Market
um
but but you know you've got to be a good
communicator you've got to be concise
with how you how you talk and you
deliver messages you've got to be a kind
of problem solver and you've got to be
able to see an opportunity and go okay
that's worth investing my time in and
that isn't
um and then you've got to be consistent
because anyone can put a good month
together but you know you need you need
12 good months have a good year so it's
about someone that can turn up and kind
of repeatedly do it
interesting
um where I wanted to to start this then
obviously look two two years I'm sure it
feels like a lot longer than that yeah
but let's just cast us back to to the
start then
really curious to understand like what
was the go to market strategy like
you've worked you know you worked at two
recruitment businesses before one for
you know a really substantial amount of
time
so what was like yours and your business
partner's initial go to market strategy
how was you going to be different how
was you you know going to stand out
um you know from the other recruitment
companies I know the US is not as
competitive to the UK but still why
would you not want to be different what
was going to be your value proposition
talk to us a bit about what that go to
market strategy initially like at the
start
yeah I think the the initial go to
market strategy was let's form two teams
that make the most sense versus our
Network and our connections and our
experience within renewable energy and
then we'll build out those other teams
like the building blocks around it right
so the idea being that we're very
client-centric so let's penetrate some
clients here and then let's land and
expand and service all of their roles
with different teams so we started a
um an engineering Focus team in power
generation and a project Finance based
team and he's experienced lend very well
to him kind of sitting and having
appeared to be a discussion with project
finance and M A folks I was when I was a
biller back in the day it was
engineering so I dusted off the old
cobwebs and uh and went for that
basically our go to market strategy was
always going to be that we're a
functionally aligned clean energy
recruitment business that we have all of
these teams as I just mentioned so we
knew that on day one that's where we
wanted to get to
and then on top of that we wanted to
offer a holistic service so Talent
consultancy contingent search either
retain sorry retained or contingent
search contract and then HR as a service
which is a new product line that we've
that we've Incorporated and and kind of
be able to go in Soup To Nuts and say we
don't just take on all your roles but we
can help right across the board with a
lot of this Talent advisory stuff kind
of picture that level we we saw a kind
of Gap in the market for kind of a
higher level advisory type service that
you might get from a corn Ferry or
something like that and actually being
able to deliver good candidates which is
what contingent search firms do like
spencerogdo and pubmatics and that kind
of stuff they're obviously our
competitors in the space and we thought
we could occupy that kind of Middle
Ground which is like the engine room of
a contingent search that is always
speaking to Canada it's always providing
great candidates but like the service
levels and the kind of thoughtfulness of
of those kind of you know higher end
search firms so so you're what are your
different product lines again did you
say because I think this is also really
interesting for people so you're
different did you have these products
sucks from the start then or like
they're the ones that you thought about
they came over time yeah they came over
time so initially it was like in the U.S
you call it search and Staffing which is
permanent contract right so initially it
was it was such contingent and retained
and we tried to push for as much
retained as possible at the start
because we didn't have the bandwidth to
to be effective on contingent search
um so we started that and then we moved
into like Staffing or contract
um and then a couple of months ago we
started HR as a service which is that's
the kind of I suppose the more
interesting exciting one because not
many people do that yeah you know it's
quite difficult to do which was the why
we did it we wanted a point of
difference that was uh you know not just
a metoo business that you actually had
to yeah you know build an infrastructure
for
and what
at the start then what was more
difficult than maybe you anticipated
because like you always had a track
record or being successful as a biller
that's different to being a recruitment
owner so what what did you what channel
did you run into personally that maybe
you least expected you think at the
start
I think at the start in particular we
found it harder to hire than we thought
really so you know we started the
business like
during the kind of back to work from
covid which was great from a like
billing perspective we were a bit too
early on our ramp to really take
advantage of it yeah but the problem was
that every uh every recruit there was
any good was billing loads of money so
they were going well I don't want to
leave and you're two Lads in a room with
a PowerPoint presentation so you know
maybe not yeah
um so we then had to hire a bunch of
people that didn't have recruitment
experience because we found it really
hard to take from the recruitment Market
at that time
um so then we kind of had to develop all
our l d processes and train people up
because initially you know we were like
oh we'll we'll pick off some big hitters
and they'll build teams for us and it
didn't really work to do that yeah we
had to we had to hire you know a couple
of grads but mainly like second job as
people that were in like sales for like
a car rental company or whatever it was
it was
um so that was the challenge was Talent
at the start for sure
what
do you think it was just the market or
do you think you could have
you know pitch your business in a better
way was it do you think it was very
Market dependent you think I think it
was I think it was a bad time for the
market but I think you know looking in
with us I think we didn't know how to
position ourselves effectively like we
had a load of different ideas and we had
like a 30-page PowerPoint and we were
just going like what do you think of all
this and they were going uh what
um and I think we just looked like we
were a bit bit too ambitious and you
know we were talking you know we had we
had this graph up that kind of went to
like 150 million or whatever it was I
can't remember what it was and they were
probably looking at us like come on man
yeah you know
um so I think in in in hindsight maybe
we could have made it a bit more
tangible we could have streamlined our
proposition to people a bit more um
[Music]
but you know it's kind of worked out
because it meant that we had to build
processes and systems and stuff earlier
how you do things yeah okay interesting
and then
with your business partner then
I'm sure there's been different moments
like this but what do you think
particularly at the start what do you
think Andy's helped you do that maybe if
you were doing the business of another
recruitment person like you which is
very typical you know you could have
done it with someone that you know was
maybe one of your first hires in your
team good relationship both really good
Builders the starter and recruitment
business
but
you started it with Andy who's got a
different background what do you think
he uh maybe made you see or made you do
differently at the start that maybe you
wouldn't have done if it was with
another recruitment person do you think
yeah I I I think a lot really
particularly around the kind of
um the funding the infrastructure the
operational performance of the business
um you know Andy had always kind of
pitched into me that you know he he knew
what could look like for businesses he
knew how to build businesses from from a
back end and you know he needed a front
front office guy and it didn't
necessarily have to be in recruitment
but you know obviously recruitment's a
good Market to be building a business in
um
so you know I was kind of bought into
that from the start I think that you
know if I was going to do it it'd be
better to do it with someone that had a
complimentary skill set to me and not
you know just two big billas for example
or two team leaders or office leaders or
whatever
um and yeah you know the I I think the
state of our business in terms of its
infrastructure is is Way Beyond where I
think most people would imagine a
two-year business to be you know our
processes our systems our commissions
our accounting our you know marketing
all of this kind of stuff and I think
he's he's better purposeful role in all
of that and and particularly
understanding the funding
um not necessarily that you have to
borrow a lot of money but when you know
how funding works you can have a lot
more confidence in growing um and you
can have a lot more confidence in
spending and one guy one thing m a guys
do is is they believe in spending money
right which is actually really I think
good mindset to have when you launch a
business is
don't sit on your money don't spend your
money on a car or a watch like you know
you need to be reinvesting that money
because it will make money for you you
know the following year and the year
after that so we got you know really
aggressive around spending money on
growth from the start and I think having
him gave me that kind of confidence to
do that
okay so that okay so let's break this
down a bit then let's just let's just
zoom in on like year one basically
because I think that'll be helpful with
people and then we can talk about what
else you've got in place in there too so
year one I think you shared with me
there's about 15 of you when was
let's just talk about the yeah like what
you're just talking about there in terms
of what Andy is added because I think
this will be really helpful for people I
shared with you I think when we prepared
for this you know a huge percentage of
the UK recruitment industry and nowhere
near where you are in terms of just like
head count and a lot of them are you
know sub 10 people
and the comments uh Insight that I've
taken from that from the interviews I've
had and speaking and interviewing people
that help and consult people like
yourself is oftentimes
because you know people that start these
businesses are like uh typical people
like yourself who you know being
successful recruiters they're now
starting a business and it's just more
about how am I going to get to a million
well I'll get 10 recruiters to do 100
Grand each rather than thinking about
the infrastructure and how we can you
know um Implement processes and these
things to help us get there more quickly
so I think the infrastructure and the
process is part and all of that is like
really helpful for people because I
think that's often where sometimes
people you know don't know where to
start don't know what good looks like so
in that first year when did you guys
make like the fur like what was the
first like non-sales hire was any of
that 15 non-sales people were there all
sales people
yeah I mean the the first thing we did
was me and Andy stopped billing very
quickly really yeah exactly
um three or four months really yeah
so we we did it we did like a couple of
quick fire deals mainly with people that
I knew and was like it was a couple of
retainers kind of thing
um yeah
we're starving it
um and then we quickly were like look
this is taking all our time up right we
need to be growing the business you know
and if that means we take a haircut on
what we we're taking out the business
and we you know we live on Ramen for a
couple years then fine but we've got to
spend our time growing the business
so initially it was me and Andy moving
away from billing and then we hired like
a utility player marketing slash Ops
person
um at what stage
uh in six months eight months yeah a
little bit before that four or five
months okay four or five months utility
player being that I haven't really heard
I'll just like you know do a bit of
everything so operations yeah her her
major Focus was marketing okay um that
was her background but we had her doing
some operations and a bit of ta
um so why did you think marketing was
the right first higher on that then
because you know because we were trying
to hire so aggressively and because we
didn't have much of a business you know
we wanted we wanted a nice website we
wanted nice print materials we wanted
you know
um our LinkedIn to look really engaging
and we wanted to give the impression of
a big viable company right and and
having that kind of like marketing
presence that look really slick and
professional I think was a big sales
pitch for us in those meetings okay that
makes sense three four months taking a
step away what like firstly what what
was you doing with your time then
um so I was really really focusing on
internal Talent acquisition really yeah
like I basically became an internal ta I
felt like yeah I was managing the few
people we had obviously and then um I
was just really really focused around
hiring people for the business you know
like the way the way that we're driving
in the first few years is like a real
heavy focus on head count growth and top
line revenue right so to your point
about this business owner that wants to
get to a million and he goes okay I need
everyone doing 100 Grand or whatever
um I would I would take more just
philosophically the view of okay let's
load up the business let's get to a
million really quickly and then drive
profitability if you're worried about
your profit per head right so
um so we just we we just went on a big
hiring spree
um spent a lot of time doing ta I was
still obviously on like client calls and
and doing some doing some support there
and kind of coaching and developing and
building out and Learning and
Development syllabus and you know all of
that kind of stuff okay and then what
about Andy then what was he doing so he
was he was handling the I mean we
basically split the business in terms of
we've got Professional Services or we
call Professional Services which is some
of our teams that kind of are a bit more
suit and tie and then engineering
construction the the the engineers and
the folks and I kind of sit over that he
kind of sits over that other half so we
kind of went 50 50 on a lot of that but
he was also you know doing a lot of the
financing stuff obviously doing all the
commissions and accounting and and now
we're building out a team that does that
so that so he gets to get off those
tools a little bit but um yeah but yeah
just just you know that that kind of
stuff it's amazing how when you're
growing a business even a recruitment
business I think a lot of people make
the mistake I think a recruitment
business is just like a recruitment team
right I'm a team leader I've got reports
that's a business
there's so much more that goes into it
when you're doing it effectively and
when you're trying to scale that you
know you need to be you need to be
spending time doing that
you said that they start the internal
hiring was you know difficult what what
made it easier than if you're spending a
lot of your time doing that I'm assuming
you got better at it what did you get
better at besides the perception of this
reality we look better yeah like
anything else that you obviously clearly
had to get better at on the internal
hiring side yeah I think we really
refined our our messaging about what
what we're doing and how we're doing it
like I mean I've I've pitched in
Talisman about 50 50 000 times I'm sat
there in interviews thinking Jesus I'm
I'm just unrepeated
um you know so we got we got really
clear about our message to the market
and then we um
yeah I mean obviously when you're when
you can track back to success and you
can say hey
um we said we were going to be at 15 and
we said we were going to be at 40 and
now we're saying we're going to be at 75
and then we're going to be 125. people
start believing you right when they see
you getting it done
um and then you know you can you can
prove you know you can point to people
and say well this person's been in this
and we've got this many clients that
we've won and all that kind of stuff
um so I think that that made a big
difference and then like me personally
doing it you know like if you think
about it and you're a founder of the
business like the most important thing
you have is building your team at the
start so the founder for me should be
doing that you should be the first
person they're speaking to particularly
recruiters because they got egos as well
like a big biller is not going to want
to speak to a TA he might want to speak
to the owner of the company
um
so I think I think yeah I think that and
just trial and error did you hire in
ones and twos or did you try and hire
like you know three people starting at
the same time or how did you approach
that yeah well we don't hire like big
grad batches right we're not doing like
10 to 20 but we try and do a minimum two
but ideally around four so we're hiring
four to six a month at the moment
roughly and you know it might be a two
and a four or it might be a six and one
day if we can or or whatever
um yeah look when you hire him with
people there's economies at scale in
terms of just like you're not wasting
you know double the amount of time
training them up you can get them in the
classroom together there's that
peer-to-peer learning they have there's
that competition there's that
camaraderie there's all that kind of
stuff right so
um so yeah I mean we've just hired
actually uh an l d person as an
infrastructure hire so that like we're
really excited about that yeah 10 years
at um one of the best energy recruitment
businesses building their l d platform
so he's gonna be an exciting hire for us
um but it was yeah it was it was me and
Andy doing doing coaching and stuff so
understand that you know the business
path that you took and the and the uh
objective was yeah Top Line Grove head
account growth but still you know you've
got to be smart with money look at the
right things so what what were like the
important dashboards that you and Andy
looked at so when you are you know
doubling Down On hiring growth okay
maybe not as focused on profitability
per head but still you've got to be
looking at certain metrics and and data
to be like yeah that person probably is
on track to like not be on yeah not not
isn't where we want them to be like what
were the important dashboards that you
look like and look like looked at in
terms of was it like okay if not if they
haven't done their first deal in this
period of time then we need to be really
thinking about where's this person going
what they're doing what were the
important dashboards on that because
you've still got to manage cash flow and
be smart with that right yeah totally
well we we have we have like Revenue
targets for each each consultant uh you
know we have like billing targets and
um you know we have if you're a certain
but you know amount below that Target
and there's Performance Management
measures that happen at different
Milestones
um so that typical stuff and obviously
before that there's a kpi ramp that you
look at right what are those key
dashboards then because I think that
would be interesting for people yeah I
mean look I think we we call them the
holy the Holy Trinity uh yeah there you
go there you go dropping some knowledge
no I mean they're the standard stuff
it's it's CV submits jobs or vacancies
and first round interviews like as long
as those are looking healthy then
everything should be fine what does
healthy look like healthy for me in the
US looks like eight four uh and two so
eight CV Subs four first round
interviews two vacancies a week okay
um if they're not working then there's
micro productivity below that that you
can get into and then there's activity
right which is the start of the funnel
like the funnel goes activity
productivity pipeline performance so
your activity is your your emails your
phone calls you know that kind of stuff
right which we don't look at unless
there's a problem with the productivity
to be honest we're not like a micro
managing business then there's a
productivity and it can be as much as
you know meetings and contacts added to
the system and whatever else there's the
really meaningful uh productivity which
is that and there's your your pipeline
and you know we have a pipeline that
calculates okay we're going to give this
much value to first round interviews
this much the second this much to offers
and then it will spit out a number for
you I'm sure a lot of people operate
like that and then and then you kind of
have performance
um but internally as a business you've
got to understand some things right
around your finances you've got to
understand your cash burn every month
you've got to understand you know your
salaries and your commissions percentage
and okay well what run rate we operating
at every month is it okay a million
dollars a month well if it's a million
dollars a month then you want to have at
least three months in the bank so you
need three in the bank right
um and if not you've got to sort out
some financing options to just to sort
that out um so we're you know again
Andy's background chart accountant like
before we got into M A like he's he's on
top of this in a way that gives us a lot
of confidence I could imagine if it was
like two recruitment billers you know
you get a bit nervy when like a few
hundred thousand every month starts
coming out in salaries and stuff like
that you know
anything that you think uh Andy's done
unlike the incentive commission side out
of interest because you might have
looked at that a bit differently because
you can very easily be like oh well it's
always been like this like we have tears
40 after this whatever have you
approached that has that been a bit
different with his background or not
yeah I think I think there's there's
going to be some interesting stuff in
terms of like L tips coming out
long-term incentive plans
um but which which we're kind of which
we're kind of working on in the
background I think in terms of
um salaries and commissions not really
we haven't really reinvented the world
with that
[Music]
um
you know it's yeah I I I think it's
about giving people a good
the the incentivization piece is about
giving people a commission structure
right that is that is good and against
Market particularly as you're growing
you've got to be better the market in
terms of overall comp but also one that
rewards the right level of performance
right you don't just want to be like
paying great commissions to people that
aren't making you money obviously right
so you know we're unashamely a
performance culture with a performance
related commission structure not like
crazy it's not like if you're not
building a million dollars you're not
earning good money plus but you know
rewards the people that are you know
medium to medium to good as opposed to
just you know
um just just straight away yeah
have you found uh hiring American people
that they care about
salary more than commission certain
benefits
interesting yeah
um I think you know we we've got two
offices we've got an office in La we've
got an office in Mexico City uh we're
opening up in New York in October and LA
and New York aren't cheap right so so
salaries do matter and they matter for a
very valid reason you've got to pay your
rent you can't wait for commissions to
pay your rent
um so salaries are much higher in La
um
so uh so yeah people are worried about
salaries rightly so because the cost of
living so high in the US at the moment
um but then you know different people
were motivated in different ways you
know some people are like really really
base focused and then some people are
overall total comp Focus so you kind of
find your people right like you find
what whatever your comp structure works
for that that's who you're going to
ultimately attract this podcast is
proudly partnered with vincere the
all-in-one recruitment agency software
that over 20 000 recruiters trust daily
we're also partnered with the
award-winning one-up sales sales and
motivation platform that enables you to
maximize the potential of your teams we
love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10 of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode
so would you mind just sharing it
because you mentioned it a bit there but
just to wrap up like year one I guess
you were talking a lot around there in
terms of like yeah you know burning x
amount a month Runway
you know me asking you around okay
you've really doubled down on headcount
Grove Top Line growth you still got to
manage your cash flow what the metrics
you look at talk to us about the the
fund and piecing because I thought this
was interesting as I said to you because
you know I've done a lot of these
conversations now he's probably the the
first person
um to say to me that yeah we was really
intentional about funding
um and getting funding for the reasons
which I'll let you explain but talk to
us a bit about that and won your
perception for one obviously sharing
like okay if I'm an equipment business
and they're listening right now what you
believe are you know some of the Avenues
and options that recruitment business
owners have and uh that might not be
aware of and then two why you think you
know that's a smart thing to do yeah
totally so so the conversation that we
had was basically that we
um we established lines of credit yeah
even though we haven't really had to use
them but we've we've loaned money
to build a credit score basically with
these lenders
um so there's there's three there's
three um there's three main Avenues you
can go down right so the first one is
it's like a personal loan that involves
your business so let's say you're with
Wells Fargo or you've got an Amex
account they're going to loan you amount
of money it's not going to be a huge
amount but depending on you know your
credit and all this kind of stuff
they're going on your money the positive
thing about that is it's going to be
um it's going to be a lower interest
rate maybe that's gonna be eight percent
something like that so Amex might lend
you 100 Grand yeah at eight percent
which is good if you borrow that pay it
back and then they'll give you more
credit as long as you're a good payer
right but it's never going to be massive
because it's a personal loan
the other option that you have is going
to your business account bank and
lending from them and that will be
better rates but they're going to loan
you a bit more in the personal loan but
not that much
uh and then the other option is that you
go to like a credit
facility one that takes on riskier
things and they're going to loan you
money but it's going to be 20 right
and then the last option is is kind of
invoice factoring which is probably the
most attractive option particularly if
you're a bigger business with a lot of
invoices out and all that kind of stuff
but the key thing about borrowing is
like and people that live in the US will
know this because it's the same with
your personal credit like you can be
rich but if you don't use a credit card
like you you can't get cars on lease and
stuff right it's a bit of a game that
you have to get familiar with
um borrow what I would recommend to
people is borrow some money even if you
don't need it because you should need it
because you're investing in your
business and even if it's at a 20 return
uh interest then you know like if you
can't put a million dollars in your
business and return 1.2 million dollars
in 12 months then the platform's not
strong enough anyway so borrowing money
in that situation should should be
something you consider anyway but
importantly you'll start to build up
more so initially borrow 80 you pay that
back then they go hey we'll lend you 150
you pay that back and then you're
building up and then maybe you'll find
yourself in a position where you're five
six years in you've got a really strong
platform you're like we just need to put
fuel on this and then you can go to
these lenders and they'll lend you a
million dollars that you actually need
for real growth so you start building up
that relationship with them
um and invoice factoring is a really
interesting one as well you know they're
gonna as long as as the the thing with
like
invoice factoring is you've got to
actually be like a pretty decent
business already for them to to engage
with you because they're going to get
forensic in terms of what does your
business look like do people pay you
back who are your clients that's
leveraging like how much money they let
your like payment your like how much
your history of being paid how much your
money making to then be like we'll lend
you this because we know that about your
business right is that wrong well yeah
that's that's more like when you go to
to a bank the invoice Factory is like
all of that but then it's like we will
we will lend you money or we will pay
you money for your invoices so if you've
got a million dollars worth of
receivables they'll usually do up to
like 90 so they're so right so they'll
just pay you that because they assume
you're gonna get paid yeah they'll take
on other than waiting they'll take on
that for like you know one to two
percent right got you
yeah it's interesting because
um yeah that's like I really like the
mindset there of again I just feel like
this is the there's just a different
mindset that you have on how you're
approaching growing this business
because like you said it's like you're
doing these things now because if you
keep going in the right trajectory there
will be that moment where you you know
you and Andy look at each other and go
right like we feel really confident that
if we can just put more resources in
this part and that part that we can go
from you know
20 million a year to 35 million a year
totally but because you've had that
track record of asking for money paying
it back
you're going to be able to get in those
rooms and go hey look we need 5 million
so we can get here
and you might have already dealt with
them three four times up until that
point yeah exactly and I think a lot of
people
um take on investors too early or sell
parts of their company too early like I
would really strongly advise against
that because like money is
um money's really expensive when you
start and then if you have any success
it's comparably quite cheap so if you're
selling part your company to a amount
that might sound like a lot to you at
the start like 250 Grand and they they
want to take you know 25 they've they've
valued your business at a million
dollars and you're like you know four
people uh you might think that's great
but then all of a sudden in your third
year you're you know probably doing more
than that quarter right so you're just
like all right I'm just giving away 25
the business so
if you can borrow debt and not Equity
borrow money don't sell off your company
and then you can bring in an equity
partner when you've got something really
you know meaningful like when you're 100
people and you bring an equity partner
and they take you to 300 people when you
do what you know the fadens and a lot of
those other successful businesses have
done
it's the second year then
what was like the mindset so obviously
you went from 15 to 43
like over doubled
um net fee income invested a lot more in
the infrastructure so why don't we just
paint a picture of like the business
today then and then we can work
backwards so when we caught up it might
have changed now you said you had around
40 recruiters to 40 sales people and
then six people in the infrastructure
would you mind just sharing the the
up-to-date makeup then of like the
infrastructure compared to sales people
yeah so so we're uh we're at this we're
at about
we're at six still on the infrastructure
but we've just hired two more people so
in a couple of weeks they'll be joining
that will take us up to eight
and I think we're at about 42 recruiters
I mean when we call it was only a couple
of weeks yeah
um but we've got we've got you know
we've got some really exciting senior
highs in the locker like we're about to
hire someone to to lead New York and
then we've got a couple of other people
um that are a bit more experience
joining as well like every year we can
we can attract like more senior talent
to the business which is exciting
um so yeah it's kind of it's kind of
there you know our really high level
numbers in terms of what our targets
were to give to give you a bit of
context was one three
uh 6 10 15. in terms of million yeah
yeah uh and you know we kind of did that
one and two and I think you know we've
already started to have a pretty good
course of this course so I think we're
tracking to to beat that third year goal
as well so what people make up the
infrastructure that'd be interesting
you've just hired an l d person which
you're really excited about um what else
we've got in there
so we just had we we started this this
HR as a service okay thing right so
um we hired like a kind of senior HR
consultant HR business partner types up
not internally for us but for our
clients
um and then we've got a couple of
operational people there we've we've
hired a uh finance manager who's going
to take on responsibilities around
commissions and and that kind of stuff
um we've got a couple of operational
folks as well now
um we're looking at hiring a marketing
marketing team yeah we've got a
marketing person yeah yeah
um Noah fish shout out uh he's a
marketing Finance lnd operations what
does that mean what are they getting
their hands in so operations yeah
operations is is a mix of Staff like
we're we're about to implement a new CRM
that's that's a lot of heavy lifting
um you know we've got two offices we're
about to launch another office there's
heavy difference yeah yeah Community
pieces that kind of stuff
um okay HR person what else we've got in
there then so we've got HR our finance
marketing operations training training
lnd
um we've got another we've got a TA oh
yeah I was gonna say yeah that makes
sense and we're hiring another ta
because we've got a TA that sits Mexico
City we're hiring one in La you're not
in that anymore no I'm I'm not I even
know I still dabbing I'm still I'm still
the first person you speak to but
um I've been doing less less in miles
and connections yeah so that so that's
the that team interesting how curious
then how have you set up the the
recruiters in terms of like
what does what does the all chart look
like that might be interesting in terms
of like we've got you know out of the
four around 41 42 you've got three team
leads what does that look like
those sort of ratios and leaders to
recruiters yeah so
um the layout will be you know
recruiters team leaders divisional leads
like there's nothing too crazy about
that um not every one of our teams has
an emerged team leader yet so we don't
have nine team leaders we have
I'd say I think we have six or 17
leaders and then other people that are
kind of emerging through that and then
obviously we'll launch other teams we
don't have any divisional leads yet
though we've just hired the guy in New
York will be a divisional lead so we'll
start that I I see like you know at
scale
um
what one point of difference that we're
not unique in but a lot of people do
like Regional leadership we're not
really about that I don't think we'll
ever have like a head of LA right and
ahead of Mexico and ahead of New York
and I had in Miami or wherever else we
are head of Texas because
um I I did that I was ahead of LA and
then ahead of West Coast when we started
hiring remotes as well and you just end
up doing a lot of like operational work
which is important but like it's not
actually what you're good at doing like
you're good at like developing talent
and breaking clients with with your
consultants and Market strategy and and
you're like you know organizing a happy
hour or you're you know doing all this
kind of stuff so
so we'll have like operationally uh
divisional leads where it's kind of like
you know this person is the national
head of
um deal Professionals in this person is
the national head of engineering and has
staff across the offices it'll be more
split like that so what do you what do
you now do what's your time filled up
with
I a lot of one-on-ones like like to be
honest way too many women like
recruiters yeah like I have probably 25
one-on-ones reoccurring every week which
is just too many not that they're all
necessarily direct my reports
because just at this early stage of the
business I just want to make sure that
everybody's getting
um the right kind of training and even
if it's like there's a team leader in
between us I just want to make sure that
you know everybody's getting the the
proper DNA and they really get it and
that they're they're on the right tracks
and everyone's set up for Success I'm
I'm scaling that back now you know look
I'm I'm a big believer that you only
want like five or six reports and and
that you need to walk to fall down
through that so
um so that's where we're kind of
transitioning to
um and then other things is like there's
cross-functional things right like so
meeting with the marketing department
and what they're doing or the CRM stuff
takes a lot of your time I interview a
load of people as I say
um so I'm doing you know
10 to 15 hours of interviews maybe a
week
um
and that's that's that's the bulk of it
honestly doing one-on-ones and
interviewing is the bulk of what I do
and then you know dealing
cross-functioning with stuff that comes
up that we like we're doing a new
website build or we're doing reactive
stuff involves offering your perspective
yeah how
like
how has Rory had to continue like
because I feel like was you doing a lot
of this stuff when you worked for the
previous company
yeah oh he was already yeah I was I mean
like I was you know a lot of people now
are you know starting recruitment
companies early and stuff which is is is
okay but you know I I kind of went
through the corporate ranks to be honest
like and and by the time I'd sat tells
me I was already
um managing a really big
um business unit I think about people
had like 80 head count
um already had like you know a legal
team not recruiting but like a legal
team for our contracts not a marketing
team and our TA team reporting into me
and that kind of stuff so a lot of that
stuff I was already doing particularly
what I do
um a lot of the new stuff Andy Andy does
all that actually
um you know the new stuff that comes
with with when you set up your own
business as opposed to being a senior
person in uh you know front office
senior person so talk to us about
obviously being really intentional with
the HR as a service why why have you
done that
um just to get really sticky with our
clients and to add you know
um to add to add an elevated level of
value to them as well because a lot of
these companies
um
they they kind of they're a bit
overwhelmed when they start up so the HR
as a service is really effective for
startup businesses
um and it's taking them on that growth
journey and like it's it's basically
saying like Okay we can send you loads
of resumes but you're not going to be
able to hire them you're not going to
onboard them properly you're not going
to be able to Performance manage them
you're not going to be able to scale
enough if we put in the people strategy
for you and give you the actual
infrastructure like put in your put in
your ATS system you know put in your
insurances and your payroll and all your
this kind of stuff it allows them to
scale much quicker right but for us it
also allows us to be really sticky with
them because they're obviously then
going to give us all their search right
um so so it just kind of works that way
and then from from a business
perspective it's reoccurring Revenue
subscription model which is good for
investors right and when you're sick
when you're sitting across from private
Equity they want to hear a narrative
they want to hear a story you know just
like you ask me what's your point of
difference right
you know it's now it's not unique but
it's rarified like not many people offer
those three three services well and then
you say well okay who offers them well
in clean energy
like no one probably at the moment in
the U.S so then all of a sudden you've
got a compelling story right
um whilst also having it's solid
business it's good business so we're in
our infancy with that we've how far we
we've got like one established client
and we've got like two or three more
real viable pitches we're only you know
three months into doing it yeah yeah
sure
um what gave what was it like what were
the markers for you and I need to be
like yeah this is something that we this
is this needs to be another product line
we we'd like we'd always talked about
doing it right so it was part of day one
was
um let's get
let's get a business big enough so that
we can service it
because you don't just want to like take
it all on and then just like you know
mess it all up your client right so you
you have to build a good enough
infrastructure let's get enough cash
that we can do it
um and then let's get enough brand
positioning that we're gonna actually be
able to win some stuff
um and so it was always going to be like
a year three thing it got brought
forward a couple of months because there
was um there were some great
opportunities around it and we were
doing better than we thought uh so so we
kind of brought that forward and and now
we're really investing in it now we've
got a couple of highs there's a team of
three people now just focusing on that
um we're gonna make sure you're gonna
deliver so you sell you sell that
service to a customer and all the people
that sort out the payroll the new things
would be on your payroll
yeah all the people that handle it so
like as in like you know we're not going
to replace like paychecks or ADP or I
don't know what the UK equipments are
unfortunately but like we're still using
them but like imagine all your HR
administrative people that work for your
business
um and it what it does is it means it
gives them a cost-effective solution to
do that and ramp up really quickly
whilst giving them actually a better
level of service because they're
plugging into a bigger HR department
that we have
um so yeah we're just kind of we're
we're we're we're offering that and
um it's you know so far so good we're
still building it out to be to be
completely honest but I think in like
you know I think it's going to be like a
really core part of our business in the
next couple of years well they're super
interesting how have you that's that's a
different cell right
have you found yeah
yeah it's a different I mean it's it's
with a lot of these things and it's the
same thing I tell people about retainers
and executive Search and value-added
services it's like if you pitch a bigger
solution
it's just a more interesting
conversation anyway you just look big
bigger and better to the people you're
pitching it to right if you're going
okay so talk to me about where your
business is at where you want to take it
what's your internal infrastructure to
do that what are your pain points around
hiring what are the challenges that
you're finding okay cool how are you
finding onboarding on with these people
how are you finding the payrolling and
the insurance is like have you got
workers comp in in Maine that you need
to go and do a project there all of
these kind of challenges that they do
that's the kind of thing that's going to
like you know pick up the ears of a CEO
of a startup because that that's a real
challenging point for them and even if
they don't go down that option you've
had a much higher level conversation
with them so then when you start talking
about retainer or you start talking
about typical search or Staffing you you
you you you're a more interesting
conversation for them to kind of take
off from
um but yeah look there's a certain use
case for it right like you're not going
to go up to Shell or Nike and go like
hey do you want to take over your HR
Services think about oh we've got that
covered thanks
um but there's a lot of companies
particularly in clean energy in Tech
that um they've got a Founder who's
who's really good at you know the
product or the service that they offer
but doesn't isn't quite business savvy
doesn't really know you know well how to
do to do all of that and then on top of
that it's actually also like a
cost-effective thing to Outsource it
there's this movement in the US and
again I don't know if it's in the UK as
well it probably is it's called like
businesses Without Walls okay and it's
kind of like
you don't hire lawyers but you have this
kind of like legal company that operates
as you in a context you don't hire
accountants but you've got accountants
that have your email as well and right
it's kind of like you just Outsourcing a
lot of this stuff and you just really
focus on your core business so it's it's
kind of riding that crest of that wave
as well a little bit and people are I
think pretty excited about doing that
and then if you think about how these
startups are funded a lot of them are
funded through VC and private Equity so
those private equity and VC companies
really like the idea of getting into
professionals to take care of that right
so you can also pitch it at that level
picture I've actually found and they go
we've got a couple of startups that that
could be helpful for honestly it does
make a lot of sense
um really interesting how you get on
with that I guess as you as we round
this out then like what You Know spoken
a lot about the the obviously the the
last two years what um what are you and
Andy really doubling down on now going
into year three then so you mentioned
New York there but what are the things
you're going into your free like really
remaining laser focused on that you feel
like you have to you know execute or
yeah what are you gonna um yeah what are
the really top one two three priorities
that you have to execute that's gonna
enable you to again hit the initial
um goals that you guys put on in terms
of one free and like six I think you
said yeah
um huge Focus again for us on head count
growth 30 to 40 more highs this year Nat
um huge focus on Staffing contract for
us
um I think I think that's going to be a
really exciting build up for us this HR
as a service thing that we're mentioning
um and then uh and then really focusing
on on getting
um that leadership
tier for us really firing and good to go
on on kind of growth and and making sure
that we we've got the structure this
year
to really take it to the next level
because a lot of companies
that a lot of companies struggle around
the 50 Mark yeah you know they struggle
to take it to the 150 200 and I think
that's because they don't look inwards
enough they don't invest on
infrastructure and you know like we've
got quite a we've got quite a lot of
infrastructure given the size of our
business but that's because we're
thinking it's going to help you and yeah
yeah we're thinking about getting to 200
people we're not thinking about how much
money can we make this year you know
what's your philosophy on keeping people
because what what's your attrition being
like
yeah our attrition has been really good
um it's been probably too good and what
I mean by that is we've uh We've we've
we've we we haven't been good at uh you
know maybe maybe getting people that are
underperforming out of business soon
enough and that sounds a bit harsh but
look that's business yeah that's how it
is but the great the great thing about
recruitment is that um and sales in
general is that everything's aligned
like if you're if you're firing someone
from the business because they're no
good like that's that's good for them
you know what I mean why why are you in
a sales job well you you're not earning
any commission go do something else mate
um so but a lot worse because yes net 40
50 head count but you've got to [__]
keep people that's gonna make your life
a lot easier yeah you know what I mean
because you don't want to be in the
treadmill of totally which a lot of
recruitment companies end up on or you
become too bloated with people that
aren't that great so what's the
philosophy on there because I'm sure
that's also top of mind yeah look I mean
our philosophy is we want to be
considered like a Best in Class
yeah and that sounds like an obvious
thing but a lot of companies aren't
geared up to be that a lot of companies
want to be you know they want to be
Tescos or they want to be McDonald's
they want to be every every man every
person kind of thing like we want to be
like a premium brand that offers a
really high level of service to our
candidate and clients we can't do that
if you know you've got a bunch of people
that aren't very good at their job or a
bunch of people that aren't really
committed to their job so like our
philosophy at the start is like hey this
is a platform for people that want to be
successful that want to be good like
we're fast growing that means there's
really exciting opportunities for you
but like take the ball by the horns and
like if you don't fancy it no problem
um so I I our our philosophy has been
let's invest in people as much as we can
let's give them an l d Ram let's put
them in some teams where they can be
effective let's give them good Market
strategy then let's really encourage
them let's treat them like grown-ups
like we're not hovering over you but
you'll as a result of us not hovering
over you uh you know you're there's an
expert around your performance and you
know you're ultimately responsible for
that
and then just to just to run us out I
just want to make it clear for people
because we had our live podcast event
the other week and one of the guests was
really again talking about in the same
way where they're just really the way
that they talked about their business
was they were really proud and
passionate about the platform that they
can offer people
um and yeah like really spoke about the
training the upskill and taking that
seriously and it was like the platform
the platform so when you when you say
that you might have already mentioned it
and and spoken about it but just for
people to understand when you say yeah
me me and Andy are really committing to
building a great platform for people
like what are the core elements of that
platform I know you were just probably
just outline in there but just for
people to understand what you believe
what you see is those core elements as a
platform as a recruitment business that
you can offer to people what makes up
that platform yeah look I think me you
know at Talisman we're uh like we're
we're passionate about both the
renewable energy industry and also the
Staffing industry like we we actually
genuinely think it's much more line
doesn't get the credit it deserves it's
a bit better in the US I know it's I
know it's gets a rough rough ride over
here in the UK like we're really
passionate about creating a place where
people can have great jobs because we
think Recruitment and particularly
recruiting the Clean Air energy industry
provides great jobs so for us that means
giving people
um good training not just training
around you know this is how you
influence someone or this is the
recruitment process this is a sales
process but training around developing
them as business people so that they
understand Market strategy they
understand Market forces they understand
how to run their areas of the business
and as the team leaders get big enough
they understand how to manage a p l and
they've got exposure to everything that
we're doing in the back like we're open
about that like we we want to be really
transparent about our business
um and then we want to keep growing the
business because
for a number of different reasons but in
terms of the people reason because if
your business is growing and not
stagnating opportunity exists for your
staff so whether that's a new service
line whether that's hey HR as a service
is really exciting you're you know
you're a great professional but sales
isn't really for you you'd be much
better in kind of like a Consulting type
role have a look at this whether it's
moving them from contract to perm or
perm to contract whether that's opening
up new geographies whether that's
opening up new markets new technologies
um or just
the Myriad of internal roles that happen
when you're growing really quickly right
and then just the typical path of
consultant to team leader that happens a
lot more when you're growing quickly
right so we we're a big believer in like
the career Journey you know that we
don't want people to stagnate we want
people to think I started here and I
left six years later doing a different
role and I did three or four different
roles and I really grew as a
professional and now I'm leaving I'm I'm
a real badass like well-rounded a number
of different things
um we call it like our air model right
attraction incentivization and retention
it's like and we've got each of those
has a subheading of how we attracting
people how do we incentivize people to
stay so how do we incentivize people to
join how do we incentivize people to
perform and then how do we retain them
and a big part of the attention is it's
like the career Journey that you take up
on you know of that really excited to
see you know where you end up in another
year or so but um
really enjoyed it I think it's gone on
the board thanks man thanks for having
me